[Musique]
Le génie milliardaire de Richmond Valentine
qui a un plan pour qu'elle devait planète la plupart
d'une population d'un nouvel âge
signifié à la vidéo que nous jouons à ce jeu du
chat et de la souris jusqu'à ce que nous demandions à nous
asseoir pour dire d'accord, mais  à qui
sort victorieux Hill man tu me connais
pas d'estomac pour la violence je veux dire littéralement
je vois une goutte de sang qui m'est fait
je suis le patron d'une société secrète d'
espions gentleman appelez Kingsman jelly je
veux que chacun de vous propose un œuf
candidat à l'adhésion il est temps de prendre
votre décision
nous sommes tous terriblement bien habillés comme vous
pouvez le voir sauf pour eggy qui
s'avère possible là où ils vous déterrent c'est
une aventure
et il y a beaucoup, beaucoup d'action
[Musique]
simple le Kingsmen Roxie est  incroyablement
motivée elle a été très bien éduquée
elle a suivi une formation militaire
elle prend
très au sérieux le processus de recrutement des Kingsmen Roxanne mais appelez-
moi Roxy les
tâches impliquent de tester votre loyauté votre
engagement avec votre
défi mortel jeté en l  comme quoi faire quand l'
un de votre groupe n'a pas de parachute,
je devais juste dire des yeux incroyables, c'est
hilarant, je n'ai pas eu ça puisque le
travail d'équipe perdant est primordial ici à
Kingsman, prenez un câlin de chiot,
c'est votre attraction qui en parle
[Musique]
I  jouer à la gazelle,
elle est très méticuleuse et intelligente mais
elle peut se battre et elle est extrêmement mortelle
avec ses jambes,
elle est l'assistante de Valentin là pour l'
aider avec n'importe quoi et aussi c'est une
machine à tuer,
il obtient quiconque se met en travers
[Musique]
vous
XE est  un jeune homme qui a dérivé
du mauvais côté des pistes avec cette
opportunité de concourir pour le Kingsmen
Secret Service chose intéressante, j'ai
quelque chose à perdre,
il vient de modestes débuts et son
expérience aucune des meilleures choses de la
vie
aucun du coup  faciliter un Kingsman sont
oui et sa vie est bouleversée
vous êtes sur le point de vous lancer dans l'
entretien d'embauche le plus dangereux du monde
[Musique]
vous êtes prêt à vous adapter et à apprendre que vous
pouvez transformer de beaux œufs  vous vous sentez
bien
Merlin Harry est un gentleman
espion à l'ancienne voici quelqu'un que nous aimerions tous
avoir comme une sorte de magazine gardien
qui vous l'homme qui vous a fait libérer
que font-ils électriquement oh ne
soyez pas ridicule c'est une grenade à main quand
vous voyez d'abord l'action, c'est fluide et
sans effort, puis vous voyez cher chaos,
nous allons rester ici toute la journée
ou allons-nous nous battre
[Musique]
oh tu sais ouais